hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
number of connected components in an
undirected graph
and yes this is once again a problem
from our blind 75 list
the link to the spreadsheet will be in
the description if you want to take a
look you can see about
18 people are currently viewing it
including me but
so this is a problem problem 34 from
that list number of connected components
so this is the graph one we'll be
solving today
probably tomorrow i'll finally go ahead
and do alien dictionary
so the main reason i've been putting off
alien dictionary and even this problem
is because i couldn't really find a free
version of these problems on the website
lint code so i actually went ahead and
and shelled out the
35 bucks for a leak code monthly
premium subscription so for the next 30
days i will have leak code premium so if
you have any premium problems that you
want to suggest feel free to do that in
the description
big shout out to my patreon supporters
for making this possible
but yeah so now let's actually get into
the problems so we're given a graph of
n nodes pretty simple so far so the
number of nodes will
be given to us with an integer n and
we're also just given an array of
edges belonging to this graph every edge
is undirected it connects two nodes
a and b together and all we need to do
is just return the number of connected
components in the graph now what is a
connected component you probably already
know but it's basically just
an individual portion of the graph
that's all contiguous
see how everything in this portion is
connected we also have
a second portion which is disjoint right
so these two components are disjoint
right they they are not connected to
each other but
each of them separately is connected
right like every of these three nodes is
connected together
these two nodes are connected together
therefore we have two
different contiguous components so
there's not a lot of edge cases with
this problem it's pretty straightforward
so for example if we were just given
two nodes zero two no edges between them
then we would just return the number of
nodes we're given two nodes
therefore we have two connected
components right one node by itself does
count as a connected component
and of course if we're not given any
nodes n equals zero then we return zero
but
clearly this is pretty straightforward
so far so there's a couple of ways to
solve this problem
so we're given the edges as a list of
edges but we could make an adjacency
list
which would make it easy to do a dfs
search on the entire graph so that's one
way to solve this problem just go
through every single node starting at
zero right so we start at zero
then do a dfs search from here so we're
going to mark
zero as visited we're going to see okay
we can reach a one mark that is visited
from the one we can reach a two mark
that as visited so so far
we've only done one dfs
search right so therefore we found one
connected component now
now we are then going to try to do a dfs
starting from one
right but what we're going to find is
that's already been visited so we don't
want to
add that to the number of connected
components right so so far we still only
have one connected component
we can do the same exact thing for
second node for node number two it's
already been visited no need to
increment the number of connected
components
then we're gonna get to node three this
one has not been visited therefore now
we have
two connected components so now let's
just do a dfs on here to mark
all of them visited three is visited it
has one neighbor four
four is visited and then there's none
left so we got two connected commands
we'll try to do a dfs from four but it's
already been visited so therefore
we in the end notice we only had two
connected components
now this isn't a bad algorithm at all
the overall time complexity is basically
going to be
it's basically going to be big o of e
plus v because notice we are gonna have
to go through every single
edge when we traverse the graph end when
we actually build the adjacency list and
we're also gonna have to go through
every node
iterating through it as we traverse the
graph and as we you know
try to do the dfs starting at every
single position so this is going to be
the overall time complexity
not bad at all but there actually
happens to be a more natural way to
solve this problem and if you have heard
of the algorithm called
union find it's a pretty rare algorithm
to need on leak code but if you do know
this algorithm
then you basically know that this
algorithm was literally made for a
problem like this
literally made to be able to count
connected components
as well as to be able to identify you
know disjoint sets and all that stuff
so i'm gonna use this problem as an
opportunity to go over union find once
again i think i've done this once before
in a previous problem but let's dive
into this so we're gonna mainly be
maintaining two
arrays one called the parent array and
we're going to have a value in that
array for each node that we're given in
the input and initially
the array is just going to look like
this 0 1 2
3 4. so each index so the index 0
represents
the 0 node index one represents
the one node and the value in every
single array clearly matches that
of every single node initially at least
so initially they do match
what that basically means is each node
is the parent
of itself so the way union find works
it's basically a forest of
trees so we're gonna have multiple trees
initially clearly we have
n trees uh one for every single node
in the input and as we go through every
single edge such as zero and one what
we're gonna do is take okay let's say
zero is gonna be the parent so zero is a
parent of itself
but what we're gonna do to one is say no
one's parent now
is going to be zero basically what we're
doing is just connecting
the two nodes right and since we know
that we just
made a single connection what we can say
now is that okay we started out with
five different connected components
we just merged two of them every time we
perform a merge we're basically taking
the number of connected components we
have
decrementing it by one so that's how we
can keep track of the connected
components
and there's one slight un and it's not
required but it's an optimization that's
pretty easy to make with this problem
we're going to maintain the rank of
every single component so basically for
every single node we're going to
maintain
what's the size of it basically you know
if this is the parent what's the size of
its entire connected component right now
what we would
initially for each of them it's
obviously going to be one right the size
for
all of them is going to be one initially
but
since we just made this merge we're
going to leave the rank
of one as it is because it's not the
parent but for the parent
zero we can say okay it's rank is now
not
one it's actually going to be two really
we're just talking about the size
if this was the parent which it is the
parent right so what
in our rank array we could change the
first one
into a two and the reason we're
maintaining this rank is basically just
an optimization
so right now you can clearly see we have
one component of size two and we have
one component of size one if we were
if we were merging these two right would
we want to merge
this one as a child of this one if we
did that
we would get something like this right
we'd get one
and then zero right we'd get basically a
linked list so why would we do
that when we would rather merge the
smaller connected component
underneath the bigger one so if we do
that we'll get something like this
right and clearly here you can see if
this was a tree the height of the tree
is now minimized before we had a tree
that was basically a linked list now we
have a tree that's actually kind of a
binary tree if you you know adjust your
head by 90 degrees you can kind of see
what i'm talking about but so that's the
main algorithm
so so far we've just done the first edge
so now let's look at the second edge in
our input one
and two so we're connecting one and two
and the way
we're gonna merge these is first we're
gonna get the root
parent of both of these so for two two
itself
is its parent but for one one has
another parent zero so when you
get the root parent of two
nodes that's how you know if they're
already connected or not
because if if maybe this two
was connected to one then we would say
okay one two's parent is one
one's parent is zero and and then what
we would say is okay one and zero both
have the same root parent so therefore
they're already merged so we don't need
to merge them again but in this case you
can see
two has its own two is the parent of
itself one has a root parent of zero
so therefore they're not connected so we
can connect them together we can union
these two components together
so this one is larger this one is
smaller so we're going to add this
as a child of zero where we're always
adding to the root parent right we're
not going to add it to one we're going
to add it to
zero even though this edge is connecting
these two together
when we add that edge itself we're going
to make sure that 2 is connected
to the root parent because we want to
minimize the height of the tree
and once we do that we know that the
rank of this is actually going to
increase so in our rank array we're
going to get rid of two and now it's
actually going to be
three and also what i didn't update in
the first go around was the parent of
one and two so
one and two have new parents now they
both have parents of zero
zero so this array is what we're going
to use to go through every node and find
its root parent
so we've done both of the first edges
now the last
and third edge we're connecting three
and four together so in this case it
doesn't really matter which one is the
parent i'm just gonna draw it like this
because it's easier
so three will be the parent of four so
for node three we will update its rank
its rank is going to be two
and the parent of three is going to stay
the same but the parent of four is now
going to be three so that's just kind of
the bookkeeping we're going to be doing
to update
our parent and rank arrays but each time
we made a union operation we
were taking our initial number of
components five decrementing it by one
and so we did a union three different
times
so we got a result of two two is the
number of connected components we have
at the end
but let's say we just had one more edge
let's say we had an edge
zero two so let's say we're trying to
merge zero and two right
first we'll get the parent of two the
root parent which is zero
then we'll get the root parent of zero
zero is the root parent of zero so what
we're going to find
since both of these have the exact same
root parent
that means they're already connected so
we had two connected components we're
not going to decrement this by one
because we
didn't end up you know decreasing the
number of connected components we didn't
even do a union operation so in that
case
we would return before we made any
changes to the graph
once we see that they both have the same
parent we return immediately
so that's the main idea of this
algorithm once you've implemented it
you've written it out and coded it once
or twice or three times
it gets pretty straightforward because
most union find problems are pretty
similar
so now let's get into the code and like
i said this is a leak code premium
problem
but if you don't have leak code premium
i'd recommend solving leak code 547
so this problem leak code 547 number of
provinces is pretty much exactly
like a union find problem so if you want
to practice union find go ahead and do
it on this problem it's pretty much the
exact same
so like i mentioned we're going to have
a parent array initially
each node so for i and range of
n each node is just going to be the
parent of itself and we're gonna have a
list of ranks each
uh you know component is just gonna have
a rank of one initially so
and then we're gonna define our two
functions find and union find is the
simpler one so let's start with that
let's say we're given a
node n1 we want to find its root parent
so for n1 we want to return its root
parent so initially we'll just set the
result equal to n1 and we'll say
while result is not equal to the parent
of itself we know we can stop searching
once we've gotten to a node
where the node itself is its own parent
because that means we can't go any
higher we found the root parent
so in that case what we would do is just
return the result which is the root
parent but if we don't
have that what we can do then is
basically update the current
pointer to be its parent
right we just want to go up that chain
until we get to the parent now before we
do that
one thing i didn't mention in the
drawing explanation because i don't want
to get too
in-depth it's basically an idea of path
compression i would google it it's
pretty simple
to understand that's just kind of how
union find problems are optimized it's
just adding one line of code which can
optimize it so basically what we're
saying is before we go to the parent
we want to set the parent of result
equal to its grandparent so if we did
have a linked list that we were going up
the chain of what we would do now is
basically make the linked lists
a little bit shorter so we're just
setting our parent equal to the parent
of our parent if it happens to exist if
it doesn't exist if we don't actually
have a grandparent then
this line will basically do nothing so
that's pretty simple for the
find function and last we're going to do
the union so we're going to take two
nodes this time n1 and n2 and we want to
union their components together
so first thing we need to do is find the
root parents of each of these nodes this
is exactly why we just wrote our find
function first
because we want to get the root parents
of n1 and n2
and then we can go ahead and merge them
together now it's possible that they
have the same parent in which case we're
just going to return immediately
so if p1 equals p2 we're going to return
immediately we're going to return 0 to
indicate that we did not actually
perform a union
otherwise we're actually going to do the
union and remember we're going to do
this union by
rank so let's say the rank of p2
is greater than the rank of p1
in that case p2 is going to be the
parent of p1 so we're going to say for
p1
let's set its parent equal to p2 and
then we can
increase the rank of p2 because since
it's the parent
we've just added some children to it so
we're going to add to it the rank
of whatever p1 happened to be before
that
and the else case is basically just
doing the exact opposite of this so
that would be if p1 was greater
therefore we'd want p
p1 to be the parent of p2 and we'd want
to increase the rank
of p1 by whatever the rank of p2
happened to be before that
once that's all said and done we're just
going to return 1 to indicate that we
actually did perform a successful union
and those return values are going to
come in useful for us right about now
when we go through every single
edge so let's go through every single
edge which is a pair of nodes
in our input edges so we're going to be
unioning n1 and n2 together
so we can call union on n1 and n2
remember the number of connected
components we initially start out with
is
n so we're going to set the result equal
to n every time we perform a successful
union operation we want to decrement the
result by
one which is the return value of union
if it's successful if it's
unsuccessful then we're going to return
zero in which case our result is
not going to be updated at all right if
we don't perform a union there's no need
to update the number of connected
components
so you can see that the math works out
pretty nicely for us
once that is completed we can go ahead
and return the result which is the
number of connected components that's
what we originally wanted to do
and it wouldn't be a video of mine
without a typo i don't know how i missed
it but on this first line i didn't
actually
declare the variable so for i in range
and you probably caught that earlier
so sorry if it was frustrating to watch
but as you can see
we've run the code and this problem is
pretty efficient union find is about as
efficient as you can get for this
problem this problem is literally made
for union finding so i hope this was
helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching